it's the first weekend since Hong Kong's
strict social distancing rules were
eased many shops and restaurants opened
expecting celebrations for Mother's Day
instead there were scenes like this in
several shopping malls across the city
protesters would appear in different
parts of the mall then disperse as soon
as there was word that police were on
their way Mother's Day is a tradition
isn't it
so I find it really annoying and and I
have no idea why the police are so
aggressive protestors gathered
spontaneously to chant slogans and sing
and in line with the day's theme
calling for independence for Hong Kong
the chance for independence are likely
to provoke Beijing and the Hong Kong
government whom the protesters say had
taken advantage of the corona virus
outbreak to crack down on the city's
democracy movement in the midst of the
coronavirus the government has imposed
restrictions on gathering and turned it
into a crackdown on freedom of assembly
not only for the human rights of
citizens but also for religious
activities I think this is a gross
violation of Human Rights
Hong Kong has not had any new local
infection of kovat 19 for nearly three
weeks on Friday its government eased
social distancing restrictions
increasing the number of people allowed
to gather from 4 to 8 we have to spread
in groups in flow as it moves the police
goal is to break us down we can only go
gorilla start anyone flatting the rules
could be immediately fined $250 a large
sum for many of the young protesters
this is one of Hong Kong's main tourist
and commercial areas it's hard to tell
who is a protester or whether they are
simply here to shop in the past police
could identify protesters because they
wore masks to remain anonymous but now
almost everyone in the city is wearing a
face covering as advised by the
government to help stop the spread of
coronavirus
most of the crowds on Sunday were part
off or supported the pro-democracy
protest last year which would often lead
to violent confrontations between police
and demonstrators the corona virus
pandemic has subdued many activities
including the anti-government protests
but it seems to have done little to
diminish the anger of the protesters who
see the government as taking advantage
of the situation to further erode Hong
Kong's freedoms and many here are
calling this the start of protest season
the big apollon al jazeera Hong Kong